hello and a warm welcome to quad Riga
our topic today is Europe in disarray
the EU was created to unite Europe after
the war but it has seldom looked so
divided as in the past few months
first the crisis over Britain's decision
to leave the EU and now the proposed
trade deal between the European Union
and Canada is on the verge of collapse
EU member states can't even agree on a
common policy for dealing with a much
more aggressive Russia short-term
national or even regional interests take
ever more precedence over the common
European good Zita brexit and sanctions
on Russia is it all over for the EU
that's our title today and we've invited
three renowned journalists to help us
answer that question it's a pleasure to
welcome
Arica Hammond she's a business editor at
the Berlin daily newspaper the tots and
she says the EU will not break apart
neither over brexit nor over the
Canadian trade agreements cita and it's
a pleasure to welcome mottling he's an
opinion page editor at the Berlin Daily
der Tagesspiegel and he says even if an
agreement on cita can be reached the EU
is still experiencing its worst crisis
ever and finally glad to have with us
Andrea Skloot he is the Germany
correspondent for The Economist he says
six decades after its founding all
forces in the EU today are centrifugal
it's hard to be optimistic that in
another six decades the union will still
exist as such so pretty divergent
opinions there in your opening
statements oh Rika Harriman clearly the
optimist amongst you versus two rather
pessimistic assessments of where the
--use heading Arica Hammond the
pessimist would seem to be in good
company both EU Commission a president
cohhd cohhd jean-claude Juncker and the
German Foreign Minister frank-walter
Steinmeier have said that this
represents an existential crisis for the
European Union would you not agree with
that
well no I look at Sita I mean it's
supposed to be a trade agreement between
Canada and
you but the trade flourishes anyway even
without this trade agreement so even if
Sita was not signed or not agreed upon
and among the parliaments in Europe
nothing would happen this year the trade
with Canada would flourish nonetheless
so you should not always think that once
Europe is divided that's the end of the
EU or even the wealth in Europe mother
lemming yours was one of the more
pessimistic voices but this is hardly
the first crisis that the EU has faced
eleven years ago for example the French
and the Dutch rejected a proposed EU
Constitution wasn't that a graver crisis
than the one we're seeing now over to
this Canadian trade deal and in fact the
EU survived that just fine the crisis
and I would say the pessimist in this
case is the well-informed realist the
crisis is not just a singular crisis
there was 11 years ago we have multiple
crisis we have the refugee crisis is
split in Europe about what to do with
the million refugees so it's still
unresolved we have thousands of refugees
still coming over the Mediterranean to
the to the southern shores of Italy and
nobody really knows how to how to make a
difference between migrants and refugees
we have the Ukrainian crisis we have
unresolved Greek debt crisis it's still
making bigger and bigger depths from
from from term to term and nobody knows
what to do about it so we have a number
of crises that come together and we have
no clear will to reform these things and
I'm afraid that until next year when
three very very important elections have
taken place in Germany in the
Netherlands and France three member
states of the you that are ache the core
of the you and from the outcome it's
very much how the reformer process and
you were gone Anders could you say
centrifugal forces prevailed but in fact
in recent years there have been changes
toward greater integration on monetary
policy and also even on fiscal policy
we've got European banking Union up and
running we've got a fiscal compact that
give Brussels at least some oversight
over national budgets in the end isn't
it
zigzag coarsened is that so surprising
if you look you're an American if you
look at how long it took the u.s. to get
integration of all of those colonies and
later states isn't that surprising to
see that the u.s. also has a bumpy
course
well the us that we could get
sidetracked on that historical
comparison but between the Declaration
of Independence and the Constitutional
Convention there was over a decade but
then it figured out under Alexander
Hamilton how to get these than thirteen
states into a proper Union and from then
on and went uphill again so that is
another argument I mean that would
support a pessimist of course but I'm
saying the the Union as such has held
but in the case of the EU what you see
and I'm with Malta on this point I must
say and it's the accumulation of the
crisis I am NOT pessimistic on the EU
because of Sita Sita is economically not
the end of the world it's not huge I do
think Sita is an important symbol and
has an important political meaning in
that on all these other issues the EU
has the refugee crisis Ukraine and so
forth been demonstrating to EU citizens
themselves who are losing interest that
it can no longer solve any problems
anything big but at least until now the
EU had one thing as sort of superhero
power but Batman and stuff in it was
trade policy the original raison d'etre
of the EU was we 28 together can face
the America and China these giants in in
world trade and and and and get good
trade deals done and now for the past
year or so we've been demonstrating that
we in the EU that the EU is hysteric
hysteric over these trade deals
especially the Germans and Austrians
because Sita is really a warm-up for the
American trade deal TTIP and and now
we're seeing that the Germans first and
now a one region of one small member
state Belgium can
keep throwing up question marks over
these deals and if you're elsewhere in
the world where there's Canada or China
you're saying these people are not
seriously we have to have other plans
the EU cannot be taken seriously so
we've basically shown that even in our
superpower superpower is not this the
superpower of the EU the core competence
was trade deals and even there the EU
cannot come together and that is what
makes me pessimistic that the EU will
come together on any other serious
problem let me come back to the trade
issue in just a moment but one more
question about that broader picture
Mountain leeming listed a number of the
areas where there has been resistance
beyond trade the fact that the Eastern
European so-called visa Grod countries
have refused to take in their share of
refugees or we're currently seeing Italy
saying that it might block next year's
EU budget because it wants more leeway
on its own deficit spending and then we
also have the British voting to leave
altogether or we command what's with the
great disaffection in the EU why does it
have such a bad rap does it really do
nothing for its citizens no I think that
the basic problem is that usually you
have a decision taken by all 28 member
states it's usually a compromise taking
in Brussels by all governments and then
they go home to the National countries
and tell their people well that was
Brussels that decided on this and this
issue and they never ever mentioned that
they themselves had agreed on this
compromise and of course this kind of
political rhetoric which was very contem
convenient for the national governments
of course now makes people feel that
this far way Brussels is dominating
their own politics which is not true but
which it has is an impression that the
national governments foster themselves
and now this is costing a prize and of
course Europe only has a possibility to
survive if this rhetoric is being
changed interestingly and I don't
believe it's just a question of rhetoric
I believe it's it's more or less a
question oh we have two principles of
right now the first one is we have too
many the decisions that are requiring
unanimous decisions from all European
classes there's too many of them we
should have more democratic elements and
it's the majority rules this means we
have to change level contracts I know
that's you know I can understand that
the others don't want that I understand
that two majorities in Europe eighty
million Germans and and and they try to
stick by you play by the rules and you
have let's say three million other
people soon are not playing by the rules
you don't have to be afraid of sanctions
then we have a receivers problem in
Europe so that would be the next sect
principle is we need a more effective
sanction system we don't have any
section but like you just mentioned the
Italians materials he is saying yes so
the the interest of the Italian people
are much more interest me than the
technocrats and Brussels so what is that
for it kind of it shows for example G
and he doesn't have to be afraid to know
why because if we applied sanctions to
Italy Italy would be forced to leave the
euro so you know if the others agree on
Italy having these large deficits it's
because they want in that's in Germany's
interest they want to save the euro zone
so you know it's not only about
sanctions in Europe is really a very
complex system because the countries are
so different and but I'd and of course
that's very difficult to tell to explain
to the voters I think that just having
sanctions wouldn't solve anything that's
all I want to say because economic
sanctions in this case just made our
point which by say by pointing us to the
complexity of the system which a
Europeans don't understand therefore
they're not they don't like it if you
don't understand it and B the complexity
of the system means we cannot solve very
big issues and there it is a not one
little reform one little tweak will
change it interestingly enough Rika
Hammond said a moment ago that Brussels
seems so far away to so many member
states but in fact the region that
essentially stopped the Canadian trade
agreement to dead in its tracks is not
at all far away for us
this is a small region of Belgium known
as Wallonia where there are pretty much
more cows than people let's take a
closer look at what happened to that
Canadian trade agreement the mood in
Brussels is summit the EU has been
plunged into yet another crisis this
time over the CETA trade agreement
Canada's Minister of international trade
Chrystia Freeland says she's tired and
frustrated
Edith Samba Ivy doll it's evident to me
and to Canada as though Europe it's not
capable of reaching an international
agreement nothing on but many in Europe
say that the Willona ins should stand up
for their rights
there have been huge demonstrations
across the continent against these
international trade agreements many
complain that the treaties are
negotiated in secret and will likely
favor the interests of big business over
those of consumers does the CETA dispute
signal a new law in relations between
the EU and average European citizens
I was wrong about the cows and the
humans under exclude the economists
pointed out this week that in fact
Vilonia boasts one cow for every three
humans it has lavishly subsidized
farmers this particular region and they
apparently feared Canadian competition
is that legitimate reason to block a
trade deal that apparently would have
made Europe six billion euros richer per
year you get you get this sort of
opposition to trade deals whenever you
negotiate a trade deal you're getting it
in America both against the American
European trade deal and against the
American Asian trade deal and of course
any negotiation balances these
difference out but we had I think in a
good working model before in the u where
the EU would negotiate on behalf of
everyone and decide to get the best deal
for everyone they have a right to go on
the streets and they have a right to
vote and that that is in free speech but
we are at the economists we have
observed this year and what I believe is
it is it as a tone of hysteria that
actually largely has started from the
german-speaking parts of Europe Austria
and Germany in where one fear after
another was I believe hyped up in in
very out of very complex details a
narrative was constructed first that the
Americans are Canadians would would
bring in poorer standards especially in
food then that was replaced by by
another fear and most recently by this
narrative that this these deals are just
good for good corporations which i think
is also an oversimplification and so now
they're of course afraid in in Belgium
for agricultural competition so this is
this is exactly an example for what we
see is a trend that affects the entire
West from Australia to Trump supporters
to brexit supporters to from Hungary to
as what we call it a reaction against
globalization between people who want to
pull the drawbridge up and people who
want to lower it down people who want to
stay open to the world who want to close
off and
that is the the battle line that the
fault line that we're seeing the entire
West and we have to sway the sway this
debate so that the right side wins and
Arica Haman those who would like to keep
trade flowing in the end of course are
those who benefit I mentioned that
figure six billion euros a year
supposedly in benefits to the EU as a
whole that this treaty is worth the fact
is neither the IU nor many other places
they're doing a very good job of
redistribution of those to those who are
hurt yes six billion it sounds a lot
it's just nothing because you know
Germany alone has a GDP of three
trillion so and this is six billion for
the whole of the EU that's just nothing
you cannot even express that in
percentages this means that the and
that's no wonder because as I said the
trade is already flourishing between
Canada and the EU in this trade
agreement will not alter anything so the
really interesting question is why do
you need a trade agreement if there is
already trade flourishing and the point
is it's all about lobbyism and mr. Clute
said while all these critics they are
just hysterics now because these isds
the investor dispute settlement
arbitration the arbitration between
states and transnational firms is really
a big problem because in fact you have
then a second possibility for
transnational big firms to go to court
or to get a lot of money out of the
states or the governments and that is
not just in fear that's not grounded but
that's the experience we have with NAFTA
and this is something in North America
we have the same thing for the energy
sector here in the u and we saw big
national firms getting a lot of money
from from different governments and so
that's something people don't not want
to see again
and that's it basically the main point
the Belgium's make it's not about
agrarian stuff it's about these
international settlement dispute regime
so multi looming it sounds like we're
hearing from arica Hammond
this is a proper exercise of democracy
and if necessary next agreement can be
can be reconfigured
that's the problem it is a proper
example of democracy about the mid
democracy Belgium style I mean that each
of these regions need to need to support
the agreement which was agreed upon from
28 member states over 7 years shows
there is there that's not democracy I
mean they this is if we for example if
we as as Germany will send troops abroad
somewhere and it needs to be supported
by every 16 lender in Germany instead of
the Parliament the Federal Parliament it
would be terrible we would never send
troops somewhere because they will
always find a socialist governed state
that will say no to it so it's the lack
of democracy and of proper execution of
democracy that led to the 2d to the rule
onion saying no to that I mean all these
details that the farmer would pay things
and you can always you can find
compensation agreements for that you can
say let's have a year of which right for
a year and then we see if you have made
we made a bad fortune out of it and so
on and so on every every kind of these
problems are sortable it's a reflection
of the European sentiments against
globalization against capitalism what's
so called and it's a reflection of this
that especially in Germany in Austria
these sentiments were growing so hard
let me take us to another aspect that's
causing people to wonder to what degree
the EU is still in a sense governor bowl
there were cries after the Canadian
trade deal was rejected by the liberal
onehans that globalization is dead and
the former NATO secretary-general javier
solana went even further and said that
he believes the rejection of cita
amounts to a death knell for
internationalism in general he warns
that Russia could profit from the
current wave of euro skepticism let's
take a look at this week's GU
equivocation on sanctions if Russian
atrocities in Aleppo continue
Russia has been criticized sharply for
its support of the Syrian military
particularly airstrikes that have
targeted Aleppo during the five years of
the Syrian civil war more than 400,000
people have been killed at an EU summit
in Brussels last week the member states
could not agree on whether to impose
immediate sanctions on Russia for its
airstrikes on Aleppo doesn t coax total
peace and also the trouble with current
European foreign policy is that we have
no consensus that's what that makes
things easier for the Russians vital
physics
and in eastern Ukraine russian-backed
separatists continue to shell government
troop positions in violation of last
year's Minsk agreement will the European
Union with its 28 member states ever be
able to agree on a common foreign policy
and really we all know that famous
rather disparaging sentence that was
uttered by Henry Kissinger when he was
Secretary of State in the u.s. he said
Europe who do I call if I want to talk
to a Europe is Europe a reliable partner
in an increasingly turbulent world a
reliable partner you mean for America
for instance well we just watched his
introduction about the Russian situation
I was and you said leading into that
that volodymyr Putin is the primary
beneficiary of this European disunity
that we're discussing here and that is
absolutely true and it is very tragic
yeah because Vladimir Putin has been
observing this trend of centrifugal
forces in Europe for years now and he's
exploiting it we know that with his
strategy is to aim his propaganda at
dividing the EU member-states from one
another
and to divide within each member state
the public opinion Germany is among the
countries that that he has targeted and
there's a there was recently a very
notorious spectacular case about a made
up rape allegations that that was
trumped up of a Russian German girl that
was trumped up to the highest level and
Russia and became a diplomatic incident
the German spy services the B and D are
now investigating this Russian
propaganda in interference in the German
democratic process if you will we know
that he's even interfered in the
American democratic process this year
and elsewhere so he is he his strategy
is to split Europe as best he can and
and this should be a wake-up call that
there are much greater things at stake
then I agree then cita than the Canadian
trade deal but really that if we don't
find common ground on how to deal with
bullies in our neighborhood then it's
curtains Rick a Hammond the ages three
biggest countries actually only wanted
to warn Russia that individuals and
organizations that in some way were
connected with the bombing of Aleppo
might face sanctions that hardly seems
like a drastic measure how is it
possible that EU member states couldn't
agree on that
well I think you know we already had
sanctions on Russia because of the
conflict in the Ukraine and they didn't
really work very well so the question is
anyway do sanctions really help I mean
that was the same question when it when
we had sanctions with Iran it didn't
really have either so and then the basic
question is also of course many European
countries really have their own interest
they want of course to export into
Russia and make money but the basic
question is anyway is it really a good
idea to weak
Russia economically because they are
very weak anyway because of the sinking
oil price and that's the largest export
commodity oil and what you can see is
once that the oil price went down Putin
became more and more aggressive
because the weakening economic situation
in Russia forces him to be aggressive
outside in order to stabilize his power
so if he start weakening him on top of
the sinking oil price it might be
backfiring it is not really a good idea
a better part from that I agree that
Europe is divided anyway on the question
of how is sanctions would affect
themselves economically but I mean what
do you think will be the impact of
brexit when the UK is eventually out of
the European Union does that make a
common foreign policy and security
policy even less easy to reach yes yes
nobody very much so that that the the
core strength of the European Union is
trade this fiscal and economic unity it
is not foreign policy they had not even
have a military to to try to it's a
nature is something different than the
European Union I believe very much a
NATO but NATO is different I mean it's
not part of the European Union that
makes the biggest difference of all so I
believe very much a NATO being a strong
foreign policy and military force and I
don't believe in the European Union
being that so maybe cuz there's what
called Putin directly and not try to
find anyone in the European Union to
talk to about how to solve problems so
that might be the easiest and more
direct way to do it let me ask all three
of you are title as you know is Sita the
Canadian trade agreement brexit
sanctions on Russia
is it all over for the EU let's look
ahead for five years and maybe for 20
years brief answer if you would please
from all three of you
where will the EU be then will it still
exist and will it in be in a different
form than now under s-clip no neither
Sita nor brexit will break the EU in the
coming few years but I think that the
after six decades of a very curvy path
towards more integration with big
setbacks but towards more integration we
have reached a turning point and we're
going in the other direction and in the
coming decades you will see the energy
going out of the European project until
it becomes irrelevant and possibly you
can survive for the simple reason that
economically Europe is united since the
Roman times for the last two thousand
years we have strong anti-globalist
entire European forces Trump the far
right and the far left if they become
stronger in the next year's will be very
hard for Europe to survive and all will
we will all look to the American
election Netherland France and Germany
election alone we know for sure if
Europe can be safe or not thank you very
much to all of you for being with us and
thanks to you out there for tuning in
see you soon